- At the beginning of the war,
the US were very reluctant about
what they were prepared to give Ukraine.
Now we're at a point where
they're talking about
sending F-16s.
How have you moved their position?
How have you persuaded
them to come on board.
(Yermak Speaks in foreign language)
- On a recent visit to Kyiv,
I sat down with Andriy Yermak,
the chief of staff and closest advisor
to Ukrainian President Volodymyr Zelensky.
He's the point person
for talks with the West
on weapons, sanctions and much more.
We talked about how the country
defied expectations in the war,
and what they've done to
maintain the support of the West.
(Yermak speaks in foreign language)
- The US election takes place next year.
Do you feel under any pressure
to bring the war to a close
before the possibility of a
second Trump administration
given his views on helping Ukraine?
(Yermak speaks in foreign language)
- In the weeks prior to Russia's
full-scale invasion of Ukraine,
Mr. Yermak represented
Kyiv in talks with Moscow.
Now, he says that as
long as Russia's troops
remain in Ukraine, direct
negotiations aren't possible.
You tried to negotiate
some sort of truce or deal before the war,
and that obviously didn't work,
what lessons have you learned from that
about how you deal with the Russians?
(Yermak speaks in foreign language)
- Towards the end of our conversation,
Mr. Yermak reflected on
the solidarity for Ukraine
that he and President Zelensky
have worked to amass around the world
and why for him,
this war transcends
geographical boundaries
and has become a war about values.
(Yermak speaks in foreign language)